I put this on the uh Twitter Tab and on
the community Tab and all that sort of
stuff and
um the question is man there's two 30
year old identical twin sisters both
gorgeous who would you rather be in a
relationship with a divorced single mom
of three with a notch count of two or
her twin that spent her twenties
partying traveling and racking up a
notch count of 50 plus this is what most
guys seem to deal with when it comes to
dating especially if they're dating
about 30 plus
which happens to be most of the guys
that call into my show and most of the
guys watching
um
you're kind of left with two options
right
um sometimes you've got option one which
is a combination of option one and two
but I wanted to pose this just simply to
get feedback from you guys on what you
would pick I wasn't sure what the
answers were going to be I was kind of
surprised that most people and you know
the result was let me just see if I can
blow this up so you guys can see a
little bit better
the result was uh 61 of guys voted for a
divorce single bomb with a small Notch
Count versus a single gal but with a
whole bunch of notches so men are
apparently so disgusted by female
promiscuity they would pick a single mom
over a gal with no kids but had been
with a whole bunch of guys so I wanted
to give you guys an opportunity tonight
to sort of call in and feedback on this
um of course offer a better solution
there's no third option it's it's one or
the other so you need to pick one or the
other and then tell me why and then I
want you to provide me with a potential
better solution as you see it that it
may exist so let's remove that from the
screen I see I've got a few friends that
are already jumping in here I'm going to
drop the join Link in the live chat on
YouTube
and we'll get started on this right away
that is pinned at the top so all you
have to do is click that from YouTube
and you can share your experience so
let's give it to uh 50 Shades uh to kick
off with and see what he's got what is
up my friend hey how are you doing can
you hear me loud and clear so uh oh the
poll question my friend is there's two
identical 30 year old twin sisters both
gorgeous who would you rather be in a
relationship with I'm talking long term
not short-term not a plate this is a
long-term relationship she's a divorced
single mom with three young kids Notch
count to two or her twin that spent her
20s racking up a big Notch count
partying traveling and it's probably
been about 50 plus guys
ouch that's a great question I want to
know who came up with it is there a Pat
in the back because it could be one of
the greatest questions ever in the uh
in this field
um me personally
probably the mom because the
expectations of the party girl are going
to be stratospheric
okay
um
and is there a better solution to this
god well we all know walked a better
situation is is better men
better men would not result in this
situation
I would have to agree with that I think
that if you had better options and you
wouldn't have to like would you say this
is what 80 90 70 of like the dating
sphere out there that you normally would
deal with
um well out of these two options
probably yeah yeah it's it it's because
of weaker societal males over a
generational period that has you know
led to these situations
I'd also argue that it's because women
tend to be forgiven as well for a lot of
their past
um they get a free pass and a lot of
things in lives too it seems
um yeah yeah okay
here's my thing the the second one with
the high Notch comes in all the party
years she's going to settle down for you
know and pay the Box
but a couple of years into that Chad's
going to come rolling out of the gym
while she's coming out of Whole Foods
some Saturday afternoon and she's going
to go right back and hit that pipe again
yeah that's a big problem that women
have when they have difficulty forming a
monogamous parabond to a guy if they've
already been with a bunch of guys it's
like oh if number 51 and you know she
settles down with him and things aren't
going her way number 52 is very easy for
her to move on to it's it's just uh it's
a pattern right
would you agree
oh completely okay all right all right
um I got a bunch of guys that are
starting to Pile in here that want to
chime in uh 50 thanks for hopping in
appreciate you uh you know sharing some
thoughts on this
all right
um we got
let's give it to moth moth's in the
house what's up what is up what's
happening how you doing man
good so um I'll just repeat the question
again uh just for those of you know the
folks that are coming a little later so
um you're out there dating you've you've
been spinning plates there's two 20
sorry there's two identical 30 year old
twin sisters both gorgeous who would you
rather be in a relationship with long
term divorced single mom of three with a
notch count of two let's say you know
she married and stayed with the same guy
for 10 years and you got the option of
her twin sister who spent her 20s
partying traveling uh running around and
racking up a fairly large account of 50
plus who would you choose because that
seems to be the dichotomy most guys seem
to be facing right now when they're
dating right yeah and let's be clear and
I said this at the beginning but there
is no third option there's no option for
guys to come on the show and say I
wouldn't choose either like that's not a
thing so you've got to be within the
parameters of the question
um
I I think it's a promiscuous childless
woman man I mean I think that
your average chick nowadays is
a hundred Notch count is a walk in the
park for a lot of women especially
attractive ones I made a joke earlier
where I was like some guy asked like
well we talked about 100 or 25 I was
like 25 basically is virginity so let's
just let's just call it a hundred
um but when you talk about the baggage
and you talk about all the extra
responsibility and all the additional
headaches it's gonna be a headache
either way but I think you gotta just go
with the lesser of the two evils here
and I think that's just somebody that if
you want to have kids
um if you want to not wind up taking
care of somebody else's kids
I think a promiscuous single woman is
going to be the way to go
um I I found in my experience
that you know single mothers that I've
run into or spoken to or or maybe even
had short flings with
um I've always found them to be more
entitled and more with higher inflated
senses of egos than just a random chick
who spent her 20s sport bagging
basically
um and far more along the lines of I
know what I'm worth I'm not going to
settle for less and uh this what do you
think that is so
I I think
it's a really good question as to why
their their their ego is so inflated
um
you know I think it's it has a lot to do
with
um
they've now
gotten maybe it's because they've had
their kids and they've sort of gotten
past the whole beta Buck side of their
High programming and now they're right
back to looking for alpha fox again
um because they've achieved that sort of
I've had my kids I've done what I need
to do I've reproduced and now but
for they've also I think more likely
gone through a period where they're not
with their child's father for a reason
and that reason is most likely because
they left so now they're looking at men
as
men are inadequate you know I had a guy
that I thought was going to be my
forever he's the father of my children I
have multiple men who are fathers of my
children and they turned out to not be
[__] so I've gone through all these men
and I've given them my best years I've
given them my body and I've given them
children and they've turned out to be
pos's in her words so I think more so
um they perceive a man not living up to
his full expectation because not every
woman that just spends her 20 sport
banging is going to think every dude she
sleeps with is going to be the one but
if she's willing to have kids with this
guy and she says this guy is going to be
the guy and then he turns out to be that
sort of you know loser in tin foil
instead of the knight in shining armor I
think there's a higher level of
resentment that comes as a byproduct of
that hmm okay all right and um what what
percentage of gals on The Dating
Marketplace do you think fit into one of
these two categories
wow I mean it's more than 50 I would say
it's between 60 and 70. I I it's it
depends on the age range I mean you know
the older you get the higher proclivity
you're going to have as as far as single
mothers and and um women that have high
Notch counts but
um you got to deal with your own sets of
problems if you're going to date younger
too that usually it's not these as much
but you know if you're a dude that's
dating late 20s anywhere above that
you're dealing with usually it's it's a
pretty safe bet you're going to run into
mostly these these types of women got it
okay appreciate the feedback thanks Ma
see brother peace all right
um got a few other guys waiting to hop
in let me grab the Super Chat real quick
he says what are your thoughts on
displays of public affection I was just
in a part of the world where they are
highly discouraged yes it is an
insecurity but it seems that they are
often done
to provoke
um you know I was having a conversation
with somebody about this
I think
I could have sworn it was Jaren
um where having displays of public
affection is is not acceptable where
they were
um look I think you know when in Rome
right if if the norm where you're at has
an expectation that you behave a certain
way
um
you don't want to stand out in that
regard especially if it's not a home
home turf you can run into all sorts of
problems when you try to you know uh
stand out and do things that are in
violation of uh cultural norms where
you're at you know where you're
traveling so you know your displays of
affection can be done elsewhere they
don't always have to be in public as my
take
um speaking of Jerry uh we got him next
let's throw him in
um hey buddy
yeah just made my TV how's it going here
hold on I've got an old school stereo
let me turn it off no problem go ahead
man
I don't want to see that's what happens
when you've got two of the lines running
at the same time
yeah that's exactly what happens yeah I
have vintage stereos so I thought I
could control it from the TV but
apparently that is not the question so
was that you that we were talking to
about public deflate public displays of
affection you were traveling somewhere
and it was uh frowned upon or was I
talking to somebody else we've talked
about that before not too much where I'm
at currently I don't see it as much as I
did back in the day but um I have been
to countries where it's kind of looked
down upon so like you said you really
just gotta follow the lay of the land
and then if you do that you're normally
okay
yeah I went out the other night and uh a
lot of the younger kids do it because
most people here live with their
families until they're married so that
introduces some new considerations into
the equation I live by myself so I have
no I have no reason to do that if I want
to make out someone you know just get
the chick back to the house so let me
pose a question to you then so there's
two identical gals both 30 years old
they're twin sisters both gorgeous who
would you rather be in a long-term
relationship with a divorced single mom
of three small kids with a notch count
of two she married and had the children
with the second guy she was with or her
twin who spent her 20s partying
traveling and racking up a notch count
of 50 plus
I had to give this one a little bit of
thought at first I know that a lot of
guys they say well you know neither
would be ideal obviously they would be
ideal but this is a question for a nice
debate so I think after thinking more so
I'm firmly planted in the team horror
category and then I'll break down if you
give me a minute here why so first we
need to Define relationship a lot of
guys in the space they when they think
relationship or LTR they think of a
two-way monogamy type model I talk about
this all the time uh with a girl that's
a higher Notch count the one-way
monogamy thing probably won't work but
again neither is the ideal option but in
this scenario the way I answer I'll do
it based on the way I date which is like
an mltr with FWB mltr is multiple
long-term relationship FWB is friends
with benefits type model so it's a
hybrid type model keep that in mind for
my answer now I understand why guys
would do the divorce woman type thing
you know there are some pros and cons
the lower Notch counts obviously more
desirable could be an option if you have
kids of your own like you're a single
dad you have custody of them and you
want like a Brady Bunch type situation
if the kids are older then that could be
a good thing like a girl that happens
all the time here girls will get married
real young they're like 32 maybe to 35
years old and their kids are already out
of the house or the kids are studying in
a different country off with a dad so
you can get some really hot classy chips
that yeah they're technically single
moms they're not single moms in the
sense where they're living off the
government but they have low paying jobs
they're usually pretty well taken care
of and they're from higher class
families but they married an alpha and
the guy ran off with some other chick
and the guy takes care of the kids I've
come across that quite a bit here so I
can see that being ideal under those
certain circumstances
however if you're talking like the U.S
Canadian type crowd uh you got to be
careful especially if you cohabitate we
all know this that once you introduce a
male into the family who's not Of The
Bloodline that is one of the most
dangerous things you can do for your own
kids if you have kids if you don't have
kids well guess what now you do have
kids uh you're at risk of having to pay
child support potentially and a lot of
these Western Nations so you definitely
don't want to do that and again this is
all just in hopes of why most guys get
into ltrs which is just for unlimited
access or they think it's unlimited
access to unlimited poon which usually
dries up
metaphorically and literally after a a
while
so fault question to you on this is this
seems to be what most men have to choose
from on the sexual Marketplace today
when they're dating uh what percentage
of women do you think this makes up in
your demographic where you're at in
Mexico
oh in Mexico it's a little different I'd
say maybe between the two over here
yeah
um I'd say 30 40 uh between the two here
it my view is kind of warped too because
I I hang out in circles I hang out with
single girls I go out in places where
people are single and looking to mingle
I don't really hang out there's a lot of
conservative people here but I'm not
necessarily in those circles so I don't
go to mass every Sunday I don't go to
the types of events or hang out in the
circles where it's like really super
traditional family so that being honest
that kind of skews my view a bit I hang
out are there are there a lot of yes
single moms in Mexico or is it that
there's a lot less promiscuous women in
Mexico or is it just it's just an even
balance of both it's kind of a class
thing uh in the in the higher class you
don't really see single moms um when in
the lower class you do I think that's
pretty much how it is worldwide where if
your lower socioeconomic status then
actually having kids could be seen as a
money making type Venture because a lot
of times they'll go out they'll work
their low-paid jobs but if you have five
kids for example all that money gets
pulled back into the family whereas the
the wealthier people and again I think
this is worldwide wealthier people
typically have less kids unless they're
uber wealthy then they have a ton but uh
let me get to my Pros for the for the
hoes and I'll I'll come out of here real
quick so obviously hoes a little less
able to pair a bond uh but both the
single mom and Notch count chicks
they're likely to have some sort of
baggage so and usually it's about the
same moff identified it the divorce
checks a lot of times they're usually a
little more entitled and they're a
little more kind of pushy in the
relationship because they they need you
to come in and be that resource provider
or provisioner so that causes some issue
too A lot of the high Notch count girls
they really don't care and like the way
I'm dating now I really don't care
either I'm doing kind of the multiple
thing I'm looking for like a main chick
or maybe a higher quality mltr type
candidate but in the meantime like Rich
you say this all the time you have to
you have to go through a bunch of the S
before you can get the quality so
regardless if you're actually looking
for Horrors or not you're gonna come
across them so I always say like might
as well have some fun um and choose an
availability
um availability is a big thing too is
she attracted to and is she available
the divorce mom sometimes they're not as
available the kids will always come
first guys that have dated divorce moms
single moms uh they know these things
but if you're like in an F WB mltr type
scenario I say the girl that's more
available fun high Notch count uh
definitely go for that and then as a
bonus a lot of times the high Notch
count grows they're usually open to
bring it or more open to bring in other
the girls into the mix whereas the
divorce chick maybe not so much you know
she has the kids to contend with uh she
might be worried about her reputation
although you know she's a single mom
then at some point she kind of gave that
up to a degree but uh again overall
neither is really an ideal choice but
for me and the way I run my dating life
right now I'm in I'm firmly planted in
team [__] okay thanks for that Jared
all right appreciate it man cheers I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out